this is gallium
it's shiny and can be turned into a
jello like liquid
you can also play with it without being
harmed
but what would happen if you put this
metal into your mouth
and then swallowed it how
toxic is gallium how much could you
swallow
before being affected and
what could it do to your farts
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you swallowed gallium
[Music]
gallium is a pretty strange substance
look how it destroys this aluminum can
and look at the residue it leaves after
you play with it
now what would this gallium do to your
stomach
at first your piece of gallium would
most likely be
in a solid state at room temperature
the metal is solid but it will quickly
melt once you put it in your mouth
you'd immediately notice the sour
metallic taste covering your entire
mouth
the melted gallium would be like a thick
paste coating your teeth
tongue and everything else with its
silver stain
after you struggled to get it down your
throat
it would travel into your stomach at
this point
you'd be wondering why nothing has
happened to you yet
well that's because in very small
quantities gallium
isn't toxic at all in fact we already
have some in our bodies
about 0.7 milligrams it doesn't hurt or
help
our body in any way and most likely
comes from our water
or there might be small traces of it on
our fruits or vegetables
so if you just stopped here with this
tiny bit of gallium that you swallowed
and put into your system
you'd be fine it would travel through
your body
like any other food does but this
doesn't mean you should consume
gallium nor do we recommend this at all
and if you ate even more gallium
well that's when things would start to
get dangerous
if you ate more gallium it would react
with your stomach acids
and this would produce gallium
trichloride
this chemical compound is lethal to rats
and if you eat enough gallium it would
be lethal to you
as well after eating about 140 grams of
gallium
it would react with your stomach acids
and produce over
300 grams of gallium trichloride
not only would it produce this element
but it makes lots of hydrogen gas
as well this could result in some
flammable burps
as well as some extra farts but passing
gas would be the least of your worries
as this is happening you'd also notice
some throat irritation
as well as some difficulty breathing
this isn't from the gallium itself but
the gallium trichloride that your body
created
in addition to all this you'd also
notice severe chest pains
and the fumes that it produces might
even be
more dangerous for you it would start to
create
excess fluid in your lungs and you might
not even be able to move
as the fumes could cause paralysis
if you couldn't move you'd eventually
pass out from the fumes and the
difficulty breathing
unless you got immediate medical
attention you would most likely die
but it doesn't have to end up like this
so please don't eat any gallium let's
just
stick to the fun science experiments and
occasionally playing with it in our
hands
another metal we probably shouldn't be
playing with is liquid mercury
but what would happen if we jumped into
a pool full of the stuff
well that's a story for another
what if